[Music]
michael thank you so much for coming
we're going to talk a bit about the
intersection of politics and children's
literature
and i'd like first of all to ask you
about boy giant son of gulliver
what's the premise and what inspired you
to write it
inspiration in the first place was the
illustrator um michael foreman
who 25 years ago said we have to do a
version of
gulliver's travels and i knew what he
meant by that
um which was to do the story of lillyput
which is
what everyone knows and have him draw
the pictures and that's fine
well i read um this wonderful
classic jonathan swift's again
when he'd asked me to do that i hadn't
read it since university and to be
honest i haven't read it since because i
came to the conclusion quite early on
that this is um really not a children's
story it's what not what it was written
for it's been
adopted and adapted for that often but
i really didn't want to do just a text
for pictures i wanted
in a way to leave it alone jonathan
swift wrote it for a very good reason
he really didn't like the society he saw
around him and this was his way of um
talking about it in print then the world
changed
and changed rapidly particularly with
the whole question of
migration that's been going on now for i
don't know what's been going on forever
but in the last decade it's been very
much
um in the fore to the fall
i was struck like most people were by
the images of
children being picked up dead from
beaches in greece or
syria or wherever and the people
struggling ashore the people being
drowned
and also the way in which we treated and
thought about
migrants in this country and i thought
well
maybe i could use this story tell this
story again
set it now but also set it then
mix the two up somehow
because um it seems to me to be
important for us or whether we're young
or old
to learn to empathize with how it is to
be
lost in this world and have nowhere to
go and be driven out of your home
and to have suffered the horrors and
traumas that many of these people have
suffered
and that we've lost sight of that i feel
that
we have to some degree forgotten how it
is to be kind how it is to be thoughtful
and since i think that's important and
since you must write about what you
think is important and what you care
about
i thought well no let's tell the story
and tell it again have a go it'll be
difficult because you're
you're crossing over strange territories
from
fantasy not fantasy or crossing from the
fantasy of real geography to imagine
geography fine
do it try it i love that i love the idea
of going um going somewhere which just
hasn't been
traveled before i did it in warhorse
when i made a hall speak all the way
through a book
and i quite like that i quite like the
idea of a challenge that takes me where
i feel a bit uncomfortable so that's why
i read it
have the satirical elements of swiss
original work
being taken across by you in this
recontextualization in a very serious
topic
yes i think so i mean just to give you
one example um there are
many wonderful examples in his uh in his
book
but there is this um
wonderful notion which he introduces of
peoples different peoples warring
together for absurd reasons
um and in his book uh
the reason that uh the two kingdoms have
a go at each other is that one lot of
people think it's a
really good idea to eat your boiled eggs
from the sharp end
and the other one think it's really the
most important thing well that you did
from
the round end and so they have a war
about it
it sounds absurd which it is but we do
fight wars for absurd
reasons and um that seems to me that
and i use that in the book that
particular part of the story
so yeah it's um it's it's satirical but
with me it's somewhat different
i'm trying to make some sort of um
story out of his story in a different
time
and i don't use the same satire that he
uses but i suppose you could call mine
comment what value does
explicit political allegory
hold in children's literature well it
depends what you call children's
literature
again let's just talk about one book
it's always best to talk about one
if you talk about animal farm all right
now you can
george orwell wrote that for reasons we
know perfectly well he didn't
sit down and write it for little
children but you will find up and down
this country that book is
read by young people and it's read by
older people
it's a book which can be read by both
and as you get older what happens is
that you begin to understand and tease
out more and more what he was saying
about the kind of world
that he thought we were living in or
about to live in
it's a warning book in so many ways you
know which i think gulliver's travels is
as well
is it a children's book well no it isn't
it's just a wonderful piece of
literature and i
in a way i'd never like to get into this
business of whether something is a
children's book or not a children's book
because the minute you call something a
children's book it tends to be
thought of as for being for very young
children
the truth is that children grow up at
different speeds
and you have i mean i have grandchildren
already well into
the greek myths and they're still in
single figures and others who don't
read that sort of thing till they get to
university you know we're all children
some of us are more grown up more
quickly that's
all but with boy giant
you are trying to introduce or make
aware
to children the existence not to
children to people
the existence of the refugee crisis
which unlike adults they may not be
aware of
yeah they'll be aware of it i think
that's another thing one must remember
that they are
children very savvy we think they're not
listening we think they're not
looking but if you think of a child
today that child has access
to all the news all the images that we
have access to
the notion that somehow they don't take
it in don't take it on board
are not sometimes traumatized by it is
is clearly not right
how they deal with it seems to me to be
very important and one reason for having
a book like this which they might
read is for them to begin to understand
that this is how it is for other
children
um on this earth and these are children
who we have to
take account of and not dismiss as being
quote
migrant uh or asylum seeker they're all
these titles no
no they're people they're finally people
they're young people and some of them
just don't survive this and when you
think of the journeys they go through
this extraordinary journey
they go through which many of them do
not survive and that leaves many of them
completely traumatized and the way in
which we treat them
it's important to talk about these
things we are a society which is deeply
deeply imperfect when it comes
to reaching out towards people i once
went and stood outside
a what essentially was a
a barbed wire surrounded camp
for um migrants um
outside london and this was a place
where
asylum seekers uh were put some of them
had been in this country for six
seven years kids at school and people
come and took them from their flats
never said goodbye to their friends just
ended up in this place which was
effectively a prison we imprisoned
children in this country for being
migrants not crying to be a migrant and
treated them appallingly well i'm glad
to say that particular place has been
closed down
but it still goes on we still shut them
up for far too long
and we still don't treat them with the
dignity they deserve
that's important to say however you say
it straight or in a story and i find the
best way i can
make my feelings felt whether it's for
stories for younger people or older
people is to tell a story
rather than to preach at people i'd
rather tell a story
and how much power and sway does that
storytelling
and the arts in general have over
politics
well i hope a great deal if not we're
all wasting our time including this
festival
i mean what we're all doing here is
exchanging ideas
tossing ideas around finding out more
about each other and the world about us
and we're telling our stories and
singing our songs if that doesn't
make the world a better place i'm not
sure what does
is the british cannon too anglo-centric
um we are too anglo-centric that's for
sure
um it's something that we
i thought we had we're learning not to
be
i mean i'm 76 so
i grew up in a world that was almost
entirely
anglo-centric as far as i was concerned
you know the books that i read
what i heard the way people talk it was
about us it was all about us
and the rest of the world was other the
rest of the world was foreign
and bit by bit by bit we traveled more
we met more people who were foreign but
they weren't foreign they were
called french or they're called dutch or
they're called belgians and then you
learn about your own family and you
learn in fact that
you have come either one generation back
or two
generations back from another country
and bit by bit you learn
that the center is not here um
and i thought with europe we learnt that
lesson that we were
a significant country an important
country in europe but
we belong geographically culturally to
this continent that was
close to us uh historically
um in so many ways and so in that
the wonderful thing about that was that
you could lose the anglo-centric part of
us
and become european-centric
and then of course world-centric and
that seems to me to have been
wonderful progress and i'll say no more
except to say i hope we're not stepping
back from it
what is your process to making sure that
you represent
other people's stories fairly
i've done a lot of retelling isn't it
it does it does bother me before i start
um i just did a translation not long ago
of the little prince
said in a way it was the easiest and the
most difficult of representing
a story because you were telling it as
he wrote it simply
moving it into another language and
doing the best you could to interpret
the sound the poetry the spirit and all
the rest of it
but keeping absolutely rigidly close to
what it was
when i've done other retellings or
fables
or stories whether it's be a wolf or
it's
king arthur or whatever um the wonderful
thing is with
ancient stories is that you are
really free to
reinterpret it for the people today for
children of today
that means you echo the language of the
original
the poetry if you possibly can and have
great respect
for it but it means you have also got to
tell it in a language which they
can readily comprehend i want children
of 9 10 11 to be able to enjoy
beer wolf um and and to know these
stories of esop and all the rest of it
they've
it these are wonderful tales and i use
what
talent i have as a as a writer to try
and um
tell them again but in a in a new way in
a different way in a lively way
if you like um so yeah you've got a
responsibility you've got to be careful
about it
um i hope i haven't gone over the line
so to speak and taken over from
um and i think i think with this
particular story with boy
john it was important just to
acknowledge right at the beginning that
this is someone else's story
i've been using as the basis but i've
acknowledged what a wonderful tale it is
but that's okay i think we can use other
people's tale
providing we're doing it with respect
what stories would you like to tell in
the future
well it's really hard because
i've just started on a story right now
which is the future in the sense that i
haven't finished it so i can talk about
that
um i just started on a re-telling
of probably my favorite story in the
world but it's suddenly become
unbelievably relevant
and it's called the man who planted
trees by gianno
which as you may well know is a very
very succinct short story which
feels as if it's not a story at all it's
written almost as a documentary which
it's a story
um and i
i thought and other people have thought
publishers what a good idea it might be
to tell that story
now with young people particularly being
as involved as they are
in the the way we treat our our earth
and how we can
uh restore it and renew it which that
story of course is
is wonderful about now tell it but tell
it with your own voice
use use the theme don't
don't divert and go off-piste with it
but nonetheless tell it in a way which
is not just a straight translation
so that's what i've done i did it last
year also with a wonderful
book called the snowman by raymond
briggs which originally was just a
picture book
and they said would you make a novella
of it
which i loved i absolutely loved that
and in a way i'm doing the same sort of
thing with the man who planted trees
and i'm teasing it out um not telling
kids everything
but just telling it in a way which i
hope will make them look again at the
story
and find it not just easily
comprehensible i don't want that but i
do want is them to be able to
get to the root of what is going on in
this story yes it's important it's a
really really important story
about how each of us can plant a tree um
in metaphorically speaking we do not
have to leave it to other people we
mustn't leave it to other people
that's what young people are telling us
and in fact it's what
we know is the case it's science it's
david attenborough
it's millions of children and i think
it's worth telling that story
for them michael moore pergo thank you
very much for your time
thank you very much indeed for more
debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv